P youtubers is Charlie really awesome
news we learned all about the first
episode of Titan so I'm going to do a
breakdown of the cast this is a new
round of the flash ring giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
leave a comment on this video so this is
actually really cool they basically have
cast descriptions for the first four
main characters and they actually sound
pretty familiar they do a good way of
describing the characters while at the
same time sort of trying to openly hide
who they're actually casting for but you
can tell just based on the descriptions
so the first one is John Crosland that's
the code name male late 20s early 30s
Caucasian equal parts charm in
impenetrable 'ti john is a cop he has a
nice smile tired eyes and a cool distant
manner however when provoked his eyes
are so lethal they drain a man of every
last bit of spleen John is haunted by
the murder of his family unbeknownst to
those around him he is also a vigilante
in the shadows he fights with the
commitment and conviction of an artist
the brutal grace of a dancer mentally
and physically he's covered in a map of
scars in though he bites to escape his
past it is often a losing battle and
then it just says series lead as in the
lead character so very clearly this is
the Dick Grayson Robin Nightwing
character when they say late 20s early
30s that means he's Nightwing because
Dick Grayson was still a team tightened
when he took the mantle of Nightwing so
you just do the math on that but I like
the way they talk about the character
being a cop in people around him not
knowing that he's a vigilante for a
brief second that made me wonder how
he's going to pop up in this series and
what his relationship with the other
Teen Titans is going to be because this
is going to be Titans if it's like the
comics then they've already been a team
together the Titans are just Teen Titans
that aged out of the group so it's like
you go from one classroom to the other
it's like going from high school to
college so that's one thing they haven't
explained yet when they say he's a cop I
don't know if they're literally going to
make that his day job like Dick Grayson
the police officer by day vigilante
Nightwing by night they could
incorporate some agent 37 type stuff if
you've been reading the Nightwing
rebirth comic he actually works with
double-teams during the day he does
actually have a day job in Bludhaven
when he's not out beating the crap out
of criminals so as TV series tend to do
you have like your big adventures but
then you have to explain what they do
when they're not sitting around punching
villains in the face
so cop type shows are a little bit
easier for people to budget out is
always possible they could add that
aspect of the TV show but part of this
might just be because they want to get
somebody who looks like a cop for
Nightwing you remember Robin from Dark
Knight Rises he was a police officer
before he became Robin it of all places
I don't think it's going to be set in
Gotham City we already have a cop show
that's set in Gotham City it's literally
called Gotham but number two the next
cast Sarah female mid-teens open
ethnicity troubled bullied often scarred
unwilling to show it Sarah's a loner
more comfortable hiding in her hoodie
than in making friends haunted by a dark
force inside her you're starting to
sound a little more familiar Sarah
experiences violent episodes that she
can't understand or control she is also
plagued by recurring nightmares that
lead her across the country in search of
help series regular halfway through that
description you guys are private like oh
that's Raven she's haunted by nightmares
of her father Trigon in the interesting
thing here is that they say that she's
been traveling across the country
looking for help and she's much younger
than the Dick Grayson Nightwing
character so for comparison imagines
that the Nightwing character they're
casting is the same age is Oliver Queen
Stephen Amell you know late 20s early
30s and then like the youngest female
cast member who's a superhero we have
right now in the arrowverse is Jesse
quick and she's I'd say like early 20s
so this would be even younger than Jesse
quick if you've been watching the new DC
animated movies like the Justice League
vs Teen Titans that was a story all
about Ravens Father Trigon she'd be much
closer to that age like 15 16 17 so like
a solid 10 years younger than Dick
Grayson who sounds like he's going to be
the oldest person on the Teen Titans
based on these descriptions so the way
they're making it sound we're going to
meet Raven early in the series and
she'll be meeting the other Titans
the first time and they won't know about
Trigon so we're starting to get a better
picture for how their past is and how
they fit together so this is sounding
more like Teen Titans with aged up
characters that's called Titans
rather than being like the Titans comic
book the difference is the Teen Titans
is all about the characters coming
together for the first time learning
about Ravager Deathstroke the Judas
contract pretty much all the big Teen
Titans stories that you remember the
Titans comic book is a little bit
different but I think they can do pretty
much anything they want so depending on
what they specify we can talk about
comic book Easter eggs but it sounds
like Raven is going to be the baby of
the team along with another character
that I'll talk about in a second but
going a little bit older KC female 20s
open ethnicity KC is a tall stunning
woman her beauty is so magnificent it's
almost inhuman elegant refined in
mysterious she is on the hunt to
discover who is trying to kill her in Y
in those that are after her are in for a
surprise because she's more deadly than
anyone they've ever encountered series
regular so very clearly they're talking
about Starfire who's after her could be
up for grabs they could be talking about
people on earth that are just trying to
track her down or they could be talking
about her sister black fire from the
Tamara system who's tracked her to earth
because if you haven't read the comics
kori is basically the queen of her home
planet but her older sister tries to
take the throne issues a coupe Cori
escapes to earth becomes part of the
Teen Titans and in the rest is history
but they keep coming after her because
she is the rightful queen of Tamara the
funny thing they might do to have her
meet the Titans for the first time is if
you saw the Teen Titans Judas contract
animated movie it featured a flashback
at the beginning where they run into
Starfire did grace and help save her
while he is still Robin she forms a bond
with him that joins the team in the rest
is history
Nannan FAMAS I did not see that coming
thank you
I am coriander of tamarin our kind can
learn language from the active kissing
useful but so far based on the
description that sounds like Nightwing
will have been a vigilante while maybe
also working as a police officer remains
to be determined while the others sort
of run into him and then they come
together as a team but the last one also
very familiar this was confirmed by
Geoff Johns - it's called Jax's the name
it says male mid late teens open
ethnicity Asian preferred funny and
charming
this amateur thief's humour hides his
insecurities and past pain not the
toughest kid on the streets he's learned
to survive in a world with his wit and
quick thinking series regular very
clearly this is talking about Beast Boy
or gar so the thing about him is they've
changed the way his powers have worked
in the comics because this is going to
be a live action and it is crazy
expensive to turn someone into a bunch
of different CG animals over and over
again what they might do is just give
him the ability to talk to animals it's
actually pretty easy to do based on the
way his powers work so what happened is
his parents were sort of genetic
scientists working in Africa studying
animals he contracted a rare virus and
in order to save him
his parents injected him with this
special DNA that turned him into an
animal for a brief period when the virus
was gone he reverted back but he
retained the ability to change into any
animal that he wanted so he was actually
born as a human but then became the
changeling so changeling was his first
name in the comics before they started
calling him beast boy but to his friends
he's known as gar as in Garfield
so we'll see what they do with his
powers it's a little bit easier to do
people like Ravens powers or Nightwing
who just has really acrobatic skills or
even Corey Corey's powers would look a
lot like supergirls powers because she
can fly she has energy beams they're
only casting these for right now but
what I'm expecting is is that they'll
build the team out slowly over the
series depending on how many episodes
they have the
you guys can let me know what you think
about all these and who you want to play
Nightwing and all these other big
characters if they can nail Nightwing I
am totally cool with whoever they cast
for the other characters as long as they
all work as a group so this is huge news
what they'll probably do is they might
have some casting announcements to make
a comic-con if they're casting right now
because they're supposed to be shooting
later this year but I don't think it's
going to start till after Comic Con so
even if they don't have footage ready
late in July what they'll probably do is
just say these are who your actors are
this is some concept footage this is a
little bit what it's going to look like
and that'll be it but if you want to get
ready for this I just recommend you read
some of the classic Teen Titans stories
really any of them will do or you could
read the modern Titans comic book even
though the roster is a little bit
different but what's going to happen
later today is I'll be posting some new
flash season 4 there's also a bunch of
other videos I'm trying to get through
so I'll add updates in the comments so
just look at that top comment that I've
pinned for my video schedule
congratulations to the latest giveaway
winner Robin Wayne please private
message me so I can get your contact
details while you wait for everything
click here for brand new Game of Thrones
and you can click here for brand new
flash thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight